like everyone if you got a parking
ticket recently in Las Vegas you could
help local students instead of paying
the fine city is accepting school
supplies right now instead of payments
those donations will go to the teachers
exchange that's a non-profit and
resource for all public school teachers
many teachers spend a lot of their own
money on supplies every year and as
exchange helps them save hundreds of
dollars the teachers exchange was really
good we have Tim macguffin it's what I
deal with over there he sent us videos
of the teachers because again it's free
of charge you know a lot of teachers
come out of pocket and that's part of
the reason we wanted to go with them is
to help the teachers who are helping the
kids and they were very grateful so your
ticket does have to be a non public
safety citation and issued between June
1st and July 14th so this is happening
still for a few more weeks so here's a
list of items you can drop off for your
tickets there's everything from pencils
and erasers to paper towels rulers and
scissors and you can drop off those
items at the parking office it did move
it's now at 350 South City Park Way
that's near the Discovery Museum so that
is a good option